Uh, I'm in a good mood and nobody can stop me,
man. What if you said that and then killed yourself,
that would be amazing. I'm in a good mood and nobody could stop me
dude. One time I was at a dinner with my friend. No,
it was lunch as that when my friend and we were four of us and,
and we were eating and he just, and we're all laughing. He's like, ah, yeah.
And he took a pill and drank water and I said, Oh, taking cyanide.
And he spit the water out everywhere.
And that's a funny joke for that that you can do every time someone's just
taking pills and they don't look like I mentioned ticket, but dude,
if you're at a restaurant and you take pills, you gotta be like, yo guys,
I'm gonna take a pill right now.
You can't just casually pop pills in your mouth and.
There's laws. Um,
yeah. There's laws, dude. Suck me off the completion, dude. Okay.
Uh, what about actually before, even that
here, here's something that I'm not doing. Okay.
And everyone can stop asking me.
Cause I'm getting real comedians asking me to do this like comedians that are a,
even like do a headlining gigs and. I'm not.
And you can stop texting me if you know me personally or asking me
if you don't on Twitter or whatever the or DM-ing me to
do a zoom comedy show. Okay.
I'm not doing a zoom comedy show.
Do you know why? Two reasons?
That's a horrible idea. Number one.
And number two, I have a successful podcast.
So I have an outlet for an outlet for it outlet.
Hm I'm. Whenever I mistake a word,
I usually don't go back and say it and I usually don't go back and correct it.
That's the word now. Okay. Outlet.
I don't even understand what, what was I saying about it?
What was the word outlet? What was that? Outlet? Outlet outlet, dude.
I have an outlet. I have a outlet and it's my part.
It's my part. Attest to the stand. Me dude.
I have an outlet and it's much harder to cast said Irish, dude.
What are words? Anyway, dude, I beat like Kanye.
So I'm not doing a zoom comedy show, man, because it's going to be awful.
All right. I have my podcast. It's all set up. Um, I'm up here doing my,
dude. I get good thing thing. I got a guy who texted me nine times.
Do you want me to do the one to this? This is no,
I'm fine with doing just no standup until standup comes back round.
Um, because dude, I don't understand too.
There's like, well, yeah, but you already are successful. Like these comedians,
they're like, well we're doing a zoom call. Just start a podcast, dude.
Just talk. Vice vice dude, which welcome,
which is just vice. You know,
they did a standup comedy in the age of, I walked,
I went down to find out standup County in the age of social distancing.
I have glasses. So they went to go.
Stay at home comedy show. I kind of don't want to do material right now. Cause
jokes BC like before Corona thinking that.
It's not even that these people, aren't funny. I'm sure they are funny.
This is just not the medium for it. No knock on these.
These people are probably talented if they get on the stage,
I'm sure that could crush.
And I also like feel for these because I remember doing stand-ups starting out
and whatever. I don't know if these real are starting out or not,
but like vice did a whole thing on.
Canceled.
Would you be down to try just doing it streaming like a live show,
but it would just be us doing it to our computer and like no laughter no
audience and no feedback. Just a podcast.
So just say it's a podcast. This guy looks cool.
I would hang with this guy.
Um, but it's just not gonna, it's not going to be funny if you do
it. It's not going to be funny if you do. That's the thing, man,
everything is different. Like I always like,
I always like try to make it
like Instagram. I'm not going to do Instagram.
Like I'm going to do this podcast. I'm not going to do this podcast.
I'm going to do my standup. I always say this. It's all for different mediums.
Some people like men Instagram, they don't like my podcast.
So people like my standup, they don't like my Twitter because it's different.
And it has to be because it's a different medium. If I were to do my tweets,
like my standup, my Twitter will be awful. My Twitter is awful,
but you know what I mean? It's like, um,
you know, I, it, it's just, it's just,
you can't do the thing you want to do so much
in this, in this medium. That way.
It's also like, okay,
Rona. It's okay to not be funny,
like as a comedian or not be rip wrongly. Hilarious dude.
When I started this podcast, I didn't think it was going to,
I didn't know if gonna be funny or not. I just thought gonna be funny to me.
You got to do what makes yourself laugh, man.
You have to do what makes yourself laugh. That's what I do.
That's all I do is, and I'm I, you know, this is an advice or what,
but like zoom, this zoom comedy. It's gotta go, dude.
It's not funny. I mean,
the best comedians can do it and it won't be good.
It's just, it's not the medium for it.
Do a podcast. Yes. This wouldn't work on stage.
This is me bullshitting. If I were to come out and have a thing,
like I'm going to talk about this. I'm gonna do this material.
I'm gonna do that material. It will be atrocious, dude.
You'd sniff it in a minute. You hang up on me. This is a phone call,
but you'd click out of the YouTube man. You'd turn it off Spotify.
You'd say get out iTunes podcast. This is the podcast.
This is not stand up. Comedy, big believer in that man.
Um, anyway, do it via zoom comedy vise.
I just let me see. Let's look up some of these zoom comedy shows, um,
[inaudible] look,
I'm sure they're successful and funny and and I'm sure they're good on stage.
I feel for these dudes, I get it. It's a rough time, but this is not the answer.
Um, zoom, let's just Google zoom comedy show.
Somebody was like, dude, somebody hit me up and they were like, Hey, uh, hit me.
Uh, you could do a set and we'll pay you thousands of dollars.
And, and it, you know, we don't record it and leave it up. It's just live.
And I'm like, dude,
you don't think someone's going to record it and put it up in and I'm going to
go get a huge. Okay.
Improv comedy show by eight. That's another thing I don't get is, uh,
um, I watched, first of all,
I watched, uh Middleditch and Schwartz and it was funny. They're funny.
Those guys are funny. Um, that's like the best version of that to me,
but long form improv to me is so weird.
Like it's just, I mean, I get that, you know,
people are, uh, the people who do it are funny.
I don't know if it's for me.
I want to try to do long form and improv to see what it is like,
but I just don't. They're just like, so what's up with a,
give me a suggestion. Anybody got a suggestion and they're like, sure.
Police. Okay. All right, please. Okay. And does anybody have a time?
They want it to be in 1980. All right. Please. Not teenagers. All right. Cool.
Um, does anybody have an object? A chicken. Shar. Shar. Okay.
Chicken please. Okay. Chicken plate. I'm already bored as.
Okay. Does anybody have a name? Yeah,
sure, sure. Uh, okay. Okay. Lisa, Lisa.
Okay. Lisa Kay. Okay. Lisa,
this car and a police is a chicken and this is 19 eight. Okay.
Does anybody have anything random?
They want to just throw out there a full four Wheeler. I can't, I can't sit.
It's a police officer. Listen, it says it's a four, four,
four Wheeler and the limit. And then today there's okay.
And see, there we go. Hi, I'm Lisa for chicken.
I'm a cop and I'm in a four liter four Wheeler split is 34
and it was just like, Oh,
E my.
I'm making fun of it, dude. There's good versions of it. Okay.
So don't come at me with this boring for me is actually,
unfortunately if you look at the cat or if you look at the uprights [inaudible]
dude. No. Okay. Just,
I dunno, it cancel me already so I can just
become right-wing, you know, I want to become right wing.
Cancel me,
cancel me so I can become a right wing in three years so I
can dip out of the shadows. Good. I have a cough. Yes.
Um, so.